ich Beschützer männlich und Wissen und
wegen allem privilegiert bedeutet das
aber dass ich mich zur Diskriminierung
vor schwarzem
[Musik]
über das reden
privilegiert ich glaube die
ausschlaggebende Frage
hier und faktisch ja bin ich auch nicht
also insofern völlig klar ich bin
einfach privilegiert ganz viel
Situationen muss für mich viel einfacher
ist zum Beispiel eine Islandreise aber
auch Zugang hat zu billig z.B brauchst
du sicher
ziemlich zentralisch dass man heute
oftmals Gefühl
zum Beispiel diskriminieren
dass man selber in der privilegierte
Situation
ja interessant dass sie heute eigentlich
fast schon negativ setzte Begriff ist
zwar immer Privileg getar aber
gleichzeitig
Privileg dafür mit dir trotz diskutieren
oder ist es Probleme
genau und ich meine jetzt
ganze Gerechtigkeit
sind objektiv ist gar nicht so wichtig
so und das zeigt man muss immer
relativieren okay ich bin natürlich eine
privilegierte Situation aber
das Gefühl ja ich glaube die ganze
Diskussion gut verstauen historische
Blicke das neues Buch von Markus Rieger
das Privileg kann ich wirklich
unglaublich viel Interesse sehr sehr
informiert durch und er zeigt ganz klar
uns was eigentlich Privileg ich rein von
Herr und ursprünglich sind das
sogenannte Sonderrecht
und die sind immer leer wurde in einer
narbenen
mittelalterswappen und das hat nicht mit
dem Satz direkt sondern schaut völlig
willkürlich gesehen und genau dir
versprochen
genau
unterwegs
behandelt werden also Ursprungsidee
und das sind Begriff erscheint zum
Beispiel mit dem Begriff Gewalt statt
also nicht nur physische Gewalt sondern
eine psychische sprachliche gewalttätige
Begriff einfach ein bisschen negatives
negatives Erlebnisse wirklich
Inflation
Minderheit oder diskriminiert werden
sondern ich bin selber arbeiten
dominiert also mit wie vorstellig in der
mit diversen
[Musik]
willkürlichen Ideen
nämlich weit private also Privilegien
aufgrund von der Hautfarbe
also was man sicherlich seit 30 Jahren
gebraucht worden ist
ganz wichtige Figur aber was ich
interessant finde ist wirklich
88 sie hat wirklich das weit privilege
quasi denn wieder in diskursacht
uninteressanter Text wo unglaublich viel
rezipiert wurde ist und sie seit
eigentlich weit freeletches
und damals aus der Frauenbewegung
erreicht hat für euch das mehr dir
Möglichkeiten nicht handelt
zum Beispiel sowas drin
und beschrieb der Rucksack was geht
alles drin ist dass sie einfach
jederzeit aber
innerlich aber auch wie es Scheck das
Recht darauf
aber sie macht eine Liste und verrückte
Menschen 88
nicht anders überschritten
bis nächstes Gestell um noch die
umlaufen
uns folgt der Detektiv oder niemand aber
gut deutsch oder englisch
richtig
normaler nicht oder ja ausdrücklich
reden
gesagt dafür
komisch wenn man seit ich bin Privileg
gestanden ich meine das nicht so aber es
ist doch einfach so also bei mir sind
auf der Sonnenseite
immer wieder selber das weiß sie
kritisch gesehen und reflektiert
Kunsthistoriker
Kulturwissenschaftler in Neuburg
privat
verhindert und der Schweiz besteht vor
einerseits der Konzept Creeper also das
ist von dem Begriff
und anderen ist so eine Pauschalisierung
andere Zustand herrscht vor allem was
schwarz und wie sagt Gott
mir sollte man nicht so und
differenziert machen
amerikanische Begriff wiederum die
sogenannte white fragility oder Robin
die Angelo wo ich finde sie treffen
Punkt und sie beschrieben
wie sie reagiert extrem pikiert mit der
großartige Aktion und werde mit dem min
aber ich diskriminieren immer
schließlich dafür geschafft und so
weiter und das hat mich erinnert an das
sandig mit dem Micro sundell wo
wunderschön aufzeigt wie eigentlich die
wissen aber auch in der Klasse sagen wir
jetzt mal wieder vorne
Migrationshintergrund hat oder
migrationsvordergrund immer Zeit wo eine
andere Hautfarbe hätte
Rucksack hast mit der Privilegien und
die Meritokratie die behaart so fest
rufen wir haben das Zeug verdient und
sich eben nicht auch noch wie Glück
dabei und vor allem sich nicht
das ist so wie die wide fragility mir
beharrt auf der Meritokratie will man
Angst
die Seite natürlich alles Wissen
sexualismus
Teil von der Unterdrückung
das finde ich mega problematisch
es gibt kein toxische Möglichkeit will
toxische Möglichkeit wird auch positive
Männlichkeit aber positiv Ehrlichkeit
geht es nicht
die Personalisierung
das Problem ist schon nicht nur dass man
das Problem ist mit danken
und trotzdem
privilegierte
Nachzug nehmen und so postet das alles
sofort
darum sich politisch zu engagieren
Politik im Endeffekt andere Strukturen
und andere Institutionen wer darf sich
eigentlich zur diskriminieren
das ist schon wichtige Frage und es geht
in so einem spezialdebatte den ganzen
drin der Identitätspolitik und das ist
die sogenannte
standpunkttheoriezentrum Harding und der
standpunkttheorie heißt
komplexe Debatte heißt eigentlich nur
dass mir alle aufgrund von unserer
Biografie aufgrund unserer Kulturen
göttlichen Blick auf die Realität und
Gesetz wirklich objektiv sondern wir
sind unterschiedliche Perspektiven und
moralischen
Beziehungen
Mehrheitsgesellschaft der größten Blick
auf der Welt und dir die originalisierte
Person die blinde Flecken aber das
andere noch mehr privilegierte
Geschichte Wirklichkeit oder am besten
Wirklichkeit das finde ich interessante
Punkt wenn es darum geht fragen wer darf
sich eigentlich zu den vielen
phänomenöster ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
das
Wirklichkeit und geht die Wirklichkeit
das Objektiv die Wirklichkeit so oder
ist jeder Blickwinkel in anderen und
verbinde mit dem Bass zum besonders das
Ei fragt die andere Frage wer darf sich
dazu Österreich
Zugang zu Wirklichkeit
ganz
vielen Beispiel finde hervorragend wie
wirklich das wo Du gerade beschrieben
findet und ganz fest nervös wird wenn
Sachen irgendwie plötzlich so da liegt
sonst muss immer gleich sehen lang
normal das ist krank und so weiter und
hört man mehr Zeit es gibt
neurodiversitäten unterschiedliche
Zugang zu Wirklichkeit und rum das alles
irgendwie gestoßen
typisch und dini waren nämlich von der
Wirklichkeit ob bis chaotisch ist
genauso okay wie Mini es ist wichtig
dass die sich auch an Österreich mit
ihrem Unbehagen und dass man nicht
bewertet und da schiebt man richtig sie
absolut richtig aber seid nun nicht
darüber aus ob ich mit Nico
im Spektrum sind wenn ich selber nicht
bin ja aber diese ist eigentlich du hast
blind die Flecken oder
ich finde es eigentlich nur radikal und
ich finde es sehr inspirierend darüber
nachzudenken
Tradition unser Skeptizismus
Relativismus bin ich sehr überzeugend
ich glaube nicht mit dem Punkt
universelle Vernunft zum Beispiel geht
und insofern passt mir einfach
thematisch System mathematisch anders
aber ich glaube immer über Realität rede
immer über Gerechtigkeit Rede wenn man
Gesellschaft redet man so auch in
Konstruktionen drin und das ist immer so
dass jeder eine instituierte Perspektive
hätte und dann ist erstmal interessant
anders
vertrauendes Problem das nicht
hinein objektiv falsch das Frauen
Umänderung gleich behandelt werden
immer interessiert sich für mich einfach
mit sehr viel reden oder das Erleben und
dennoch bis zur Expertin werden und den
Lichter ja prinzipiell möglich das finde
ich aber man muss immer wieder zulassen
und ich glaube man muss auch wirklich
den Menschen Stimmen geben also das
finde ich auch richtig dass wenn man es
Podium setzt nicht immer über Betroffene
Gerät sondern betroffen hier selber
verrückt
Männer sich unterhalten
um privilege ist das wichtige
sensibilisieren oder politische
kampfbegriffe zum Thema Finanzen mit der
politologien Emilia Rock und da ist mit
dem französischen Schriftsteller Eduard